[Music]
somebody told me that you uh get
shirtless picture requests is that
accurate I do I used to uh I was on this
show called Happy Endings and and they
um oh thank
you thank you um and uh and uh uh I
played a gay character and and there was
a rush at the beginning of the show when
the show was first on where I used to
get insane amounts of of requests for
shirtless picks which from you just you
I mean yeah just me from from a lot of
my gay fans um which the only fans I
have and um and and it sounds so quaint
in the midwestern accent my gay
fans which are the only fans I have I
can make anything sound like super
humble yeah yeah um I drive a
BMW you are a terror I know um uh and so
what what were we talking about uh
shirtless picks requests for them this
is going nowhere uh and um but I got a
lot of requests for shirtless piics and
and and I just I didn't know what to do
because it was like filling up my
Facebook page you know like just people
would would comment like you know I'm a
huge fan of send me a shirtless pick and
and my family members and my wife would
get like kind of like that's a lot
because it wasn't just like one or two
where you could laugh it off it was like
a hundred just like on your Facebook
page know where you're like usually like
putting pictures of your kids and like
like other people's sunsets right right
right you know and then there was like a
hundred basically like bare bikers who
were like hey I love that uh Max
character send me a shirtless
PIR uh and so and like it it got so much
that my wife was like let's just do it
let's just send a shirtless pick because
this one guy just kept going at it going
at it going at it so I was like all
right let's let's send a shirtless pick
it
so so it was horrible so uh one morning
like my wife and I were lying in bed and
I just kind of like like leaned over
like this my gut was like hanging over I
have bad tattoos that now have stretch
marks in between
them like four skin tags and she took
the picture and I and I put on Facebook
and I sent to the guy and I was like
here dude uh you know I hope this helps
whatever you're going for I hope this
helps well I mean I don't know you know
and uh he never
responded you know what I would have
done what take an actual photo mail it
in the envelope with your son's
forkin yeah that's a toer yeah that's a
that's a confusing twofer that's a
straight up hate crime s someone of for
[Music]
skin